[Music]
that's so much why you rocking the
sunglasses
looking I'm I'm I'm not trying to be
cool by wearing my sunglasses inside
guys I had an eye exam earlier today
because I was thinking about doing ICL
surgery and in case it looked like I was
just tripping balls no they just dilated
my pupils to check them uh so the lights
were very bright on my eyes this entire
podcast so we finally found say
something corny as like my future is too
bright so I'm just going yeah like [__]
yeah you know
M got to wear shades yeah that's that's
what Roland said he was like when I
asked him I was like why do you always
wear sunglasses inside he's like oh it's
just cuz my future's too bright I
remember seeing one time he was he was
balding and then cuz obviously his whole
thing is that he looks hot and sexy
perect and then he said like his
response to like the person who asked
him was like I don't need hair that
can't keep up with
me I was like [__] I should steal that
dude he he has so he's like a oneliner
machine like my favorite one anecdote
was like you know cuz he's like a
massive anime fan right but like he like
the some of the anime he's into it's
kind of questionable so so his favorite
show of all time his favorite anime is d
cubu right which if you don't know is an
anime uh about a a teacher who manages a
elementary school girl basketball team
right so when you look at the cover of
this show pretty sus right Roland loves
that [__] right and he said he mentioned
that in the video just very casually and
and overnight he lost like 10,000
Twitter followers yeah like he even like
States like he read write novels right
yeah yeah yeah like he's like proper
degenerate right and in response to that
he tweeted out this amazing tweet where
he was like yeah so after I said uh do
CU was my favorite anime I lost like a
bunch of Twitter followers but I'm not
going to look down about it the only
time I look down is when I'm tying my
shoes in the morning oh wow another one
nighter another one and I'm just like
damn how I don't know how he manages to
act like such like
a what's the word just coincidential
cool guy like not yeah but just like so
like uh you know up himself and just
like so like yeah I'm the [__] best
but he's the one dude where I'm like you
know what you're right yeah you go off
if you do it you just got to commit to
it you know yeah totally and that's the
energy that he has so now you have to do
that with the sunglasses is what I'm is
what I'm getting at was the whole
workaround that was the whole work
around for that yeah um yeah you've
already
fa he's
alreadying you can't say um yeah you
can't say
um already fail already fa I'm trying
I'm trying to like cut out um from my
talking it's very tough though I find it
impossible which is why I'm glad that I
do scripted content because I've
realized after 3 years of trash taste
sometime my brain just don't function
the way I wanted to and but like your
everyday life though like you have to
talk yeah I know I know you have to talk
every day like how you you just sound so
much more concise if you're never uming
and aring I just want to get to the
point like like where n r is at where
he's just he he's managed to just cut
out all you know cut likes as well yeah
I need to cut out cut out all three
terrible with it unforunately my brain
like a lot yeah but it's just like such
a good word you know like it's such a
good natural filler word yeah now that
I'm thinking about it I'm I'm thinking
so heavily about not saying like or and
it's hurting my brain it just takes so
much mental energy also I've just
realized that my brain is just not
concise at all some I I don't know if
this is a my brain thing but sometimes I
like I try to say a sentence and then my
brain just short circuits and I'm like I
was going to say a point and I've
forgotten it mid sentence so it's just
part of aging
process is it I feel slower getting old
early stage Dimension that's what that
is hey what's the Japanese word you
often say like it's kind of like in
English
or it's words like that say something to
me I don't understand I'm like
uh
what say it again please you know even
when you're speaking in Japanese right
it's very difficult in an in just a
casual conversation to not say things
like Anor and and because it's such easy
makes you sound more FL if you say it in
Japanese oh yeah if you're a foreigner
all you have to do is just say a bunch
of UN
and you're like wow he's been living
here a long
time no the one that always impresses
the Japanese people where you're like
yeah
speak accent yeah but if you if you
can't get to that point just just throw
in a couple of
yeah and immediately you sound fluent I
know like you have to be kind of
ambiguous speak in Japanese right
totally totally it's kind of like the
same as like yeah toally you don't you
don't actually it's not yes so no most
of the time it's not black and Hawai
I've noticed though when you speak
English you don't really say a lot of
like likes and arms and rs like you your
English is insane your English is very
your English is more concise than our
English cuz I want to have a good
grammar and syntax like when I'm
speaking Japanese I don't care like I'm
native speaker like I can say whatever
but when you're speaking a foreign
language like second language then you
want to sound smart or you got education
so you want
put that into a sentence so I I just cuz
obviously from from knowing two
languages and learning a third I'm just
so impressed that you're able to your
English is so [__] good and you know
all the slang without ever having to
live in in an English speaking country I
think is how the [__] do you do that I
love watching TV shows that's crazy I I
don't know how you the whole reason I
have VPN is to watch some shows
i99 I have to wait for like forever you
watch all Brooklyn 99 yes I am 99 damn
99 that's so funny wait so what so what
was some of like the shows other than
Brooklyn 99 that you used to like I I
[__] said it again what what were the
shows you used to you know get better at
your English or like learn all the uh
slang and stuff like that oh I am
watching AI MC and they talk fast and
they put a lot of words and that's a
Lego show so you can sound smart trying
to sound like that actually oh yeah suit
too uh it was more romantic more serious
legal yeah I think show was like friends
you can learn
jokes I mean I I I watch suits and this
is like the Su ass I I kind of like it
it's kind of like a guilty pleasure for
me cuz it's like people do the first
season or two was pretty good people do
not talk like this but it feels like
this is dialogue written by someone
taking a shower and can imagining like
the shower bottles like Harvey were
getting sued Su them back I don't care
what it takes half of the dialogue in
suit is just people just throwing a file
down and just walking off after saying
like a stinger and that that's like the
dialogue ensu and it doesn't replicate
reality but I'm like this is the I'd
like to think if I had an office in
Manhattan I'd be doing I'd behaving like
that for no reason just because you can
she feels like the right thing to do
yeah I watch a think a lot more comedy
because they talk a lot in comedy and
you can also learn the jokes you know
you can learn the culture of Comedy
there should watch o Sunny in
Philadelphia oh yeah
that's what you'll learn
racism you you'll learn what not to say
you'll learn what not to say but you'll
have a good time doing it maybe yeah
always sunny is very good actually also
the shows like the office us like I've
only watched the US version I haven't
watched the original version but the
first season he's like what's the F like
like is it okay to like to joke about
this kind of thing but then it grows on
you like you're going to start Ling the
character actually the first season is I
think it was not well received cuz it
was too much like the British one
in the UK we like a lot more like
cynical yeah like not not people not
being happy in our comedy we like goes
wrong for our main characters yeah so a
lot of British comedy is more really
awkward and cring deprecating very much
so um think where I get a lot of my
humor from which is why in my videos I
really like the kind of cringe and
awkward kind of like the pole dancing
and the stripper I I like it when it's
like really kind of
like it's hard to watch but you can't
look away think your viewers enjoy that
they actually tell me to just please
torture Conor Moore they tell you this
yeah at the oh my God like [__] him up
please do more please do more Jes we
want to see him break on camera oh my
God I don't think anything could break
me oh wow that's a challeng that sounds
like a challenge I don't think so I
think I'd be fine with anything wow but
yeah I think British yeah I mean British
humor and American humor are very very
different and it doesn't always
translate over uh especially when
there's been so many examples of
Americans taking TV British TV shows and
it just being kind of a disaster the
office is probably the only show that I
think they've translated over well and
that was after the first season and
that's just because they play to the
strengths of like American culture and
American humor as opposed to trying to
recreate I like the US office more than
the British one I think it's better now
as yeah I it's better but that's because
the British office only has like two
seasons yeah we we we don't we don't
make a lot episodes show kind of like in
Japan yeah we normally do like six
episodes or 10 Max we don't really do
more than that in a season yeah I mean
like everyone forgets like Mr Bean only
had like 10 episodes wow it was one
season it was one season and and a and a
movie or two but like everyone just
assumes like oh yeah Mr Bean had like 40
Seasons right it's like no they're not
going to try to make more money like in
an easy way w i that's how it that's not
how it works but considering the amount
of mileage they've got gotten out of
that one blood animated TV show Christ
yeah even in Japan sometimes they tried
to make more episode for the anime that
was already good but they they want to
make more money and they kind of fell
like I wish not talk about boruto yeah
or all taxi the movie like we watch it
together like oh damn I hope like they
didn't add that extra thing yeah we went
we went to go watch the OD Taxi movie
together and uh I'd watched all of odd
Taxi and I remember it was pretty dialog
heavy so I was like okay I think I'll be
fine to watch it but it was just kind of
like a
rehash with like they were like we've
added so many new scenes and they only
added like Quenton Tarantino es Diner
interviews where the characters would
give it was so weird it was very meta
the characters would be interviewed
about the events that were happening
like like a like like a like mentary
yeah like a mockumentary yeah so they
like imagine if they just reframed all
of OD taxi as a mockumentary and that
was the movie it's kind of what they did
with the Edward you don't know if you
remember the show it's about lesbians
and they added like a the final Arc like
a final season was so weird and I think
they're just making or they have started
like a new season after so many
years which show is this uh the L word
the oh the l oh I've never heard of that
yeah no I remember this one it was
probably the most successful like a big
show about um one of the big shows about
on L is that a British show no it's
American it's it's based in La I've
never heard of this F okay yeah I think
I'm
done no I have heard of it but I've
never watched it uh because it I
remember it airing when I was I think in
school it must have been a very very
long time ago at Le School University
after sex in the city so many show in
the city I did and I tried to get some
English words from
it so is this how all Western men are
supposed to be like yeah this is how
women talk in New
York yeah and they have a new season too
like after all years like new season
yeah they had two movies and they have a
new season wow yeah yeah I didn't know
was pretty day city was pretty big no it
was it was massive I mean itally never
seen an episode it was a cultural
phenomenon but like so was friends you
know and does anyone still talk about
friends does anyone still I do still
want to watch friends and you can watch
my sister's like a huge fan that show
like constantly is rewatching friend you
think it's a apparently
so fans of the show will say yes um I I
was never really a fan of the show I
like some episodes that were kind of
funny but I mean it's just all right I
guess I'm glad I didn't like add more
episode they had Joey after that but you
know it ended so quickly oh yeah the
Joey spin-off show yeah they did do that
they could try more but I'm GL they
didn't now he hosting Top
Care he's not doing anymore right no
he's not doc Top Gear is Top Gear still
the thing anymore I don't I don't even
know oh okay Sal thing I also hope oh
sorry I also hope they didn't make code
GS more I
hope they did not
wasid watch
uh the Exile did you watch that was that
they had like the spinoff that was okay
cuz it was a spin-off that was set
during the time of the main or I can't
remember it was during but it was like a
side story so I'm like I'm good side
stories but they made a sequel to code
gas in the movies yeah where it was
Louch of the Resurrection where came
back I completely forgot about that and
uh UND did everything that was good
about the the end they brought back
loose too and they like oh wow like why
did you do that I can't wait for the
Death Note
remake light gets
revived yeah that's what I like about
the liveaction movie of this note
because they gave us the old ending
which one the first one in Japan the
Japanese one right yeah that's that's
definitely the best right like L
actually winning against like KN and
that's what we needed and let's just end
there